DI-ANN EISNOR: Hello.
My name is Di-Ann Eisnor,
and I'm the director
of growth for Waze.
For anyone who
doesn't know, Waze
is the free crowdsource
navigation and real time
traffic application.
Our goal is to save
five minutes a day,
every day for our more than 50
million users around the world.
With so many Wazers
driving around every day,
we have an unprecedented amount
of traffic, speeds, routes,
incidents, enclosure.
Our cities though,
are congested.
Our mobility solutions are
expensive, and they're static.
We need solutions for
now, an on demand world
at the speed of mobile that
can adapt to our rapidly
changing mobility patterns.
So today I'm going to share
a program that we recently
started to use all
of the data we're
able to collect from those
users around the world
as a way to improve mobility
in our most congested cities.
We call this the Connected
Citizens Program.
So we share publicly available
data on incidents enclosures
and we feed that
into the cities.
In exchange, we get their
incidence enclosures.
So for us, it's
critical that we're not
going to be the app sending
people over the closed bridge,
and this is a very
difficult problem to solve.
The premise is we can
save not just individuals
five minutes a day, but
look at the city as a whole.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-In Rio de Janerio,
Brazil, traffic
is a very important issue.
We have almost 7 million
people here going from A to B
to C to D. From the first
phone call that we have,
two weeks later, we were there
inside of Waze application
with API's, bringing
to the operation center
every information that
we agree to share.
-We have the channel,
we have the data,
and we need to shorten the
distance between the citizens
and the city hall.
-We 400,000 Wazers
in Rio de Janeiro.
50,000 users every day.
It's like we have an army of
public agents talking to us.
As many Wazers that we have,
the more this number grows,
more efficient and
more [INAUDIBLE]
this tool will work.
[END PLAYBACK]
DI-ANN EISNOR: So
it's important to us
that we're looking at mobility
patterns around the world
as we collaborate
in the solution.
So you can see here, that
we have a really pretty
good geographic spread.
More than 50 million users.
In Rio alone, which you just
saw, we have more than 150,000
every day.
And they Connected Citizens
Program is now live in 32
cities and DOT's.
So the data that we're
sharing and receiving-- it's
usually the closures
that are due to things
like construction, protests,
marathons, parades,
and incidents-- like
traffic itself and accident.
Also, what are
the unusual things
that are happening on
the road in real time?
Is there a drastic
change in the speed
in which people are
driving or the patterns
in which they're driving?
Hazard such as ice,
flooding-- anything that's
needed to stay safe and
informed on the road, that's
the information that we care
about and we want to provide.
So the distribution is
a key piece as well.
We need to make sure
that this data gets
into the hands of as
many people as possible.
So we use the app itself,
the notifications, inbox,
closures right on the map, and
the live map at our website.
We use social media.
We do have dedicated
series of Twitter
feeds for many of the cities,
and they are constantly
streaming anything
unusual we can find
so that people are alerted.
Here's an example of a
closure and an inbox.
It's marked on the
map, and users will
be routed around the closure.
And more details about it
and when it might finish
will be in your inbox.
We alert people in real
time as changes occur,
and now importantly,
the same data
is seen in traffic management
centers around the world
so it can be used to
solve those problems.
Here's an example from Guatemala
of an unusual traffic event.
We're looking for major
changes in the speed
and behavior in real time,
not just small changes.
So if we find something where
there's a drastic change,
we try to correlate
it to a report
that we have inside
of our application.
In this particular
case, it's an accident.
You can see police there.
We want people to be able to
understand what's happening
and why.
Here's another example from
Obama's visit to San Francisco.
So on the live map, you can
see the exchanging routes
throughout the day.
You can see user
generated photos
that are coming in
from our users, which
provide important context
for cities but also
for broadcasters and Wazers.
And lastly, you'll
see that there's
a lot of gratitude
happening in social media.
So we feel like
there's a real need
for this kind of
information, and we
try our best to provide it.
From the city perspective, there
are three tangible benefits.
One is on integrating the
information because they
don't have access to a lot.
Communicating with
their citizen base.
And then of course,
analyzing that information
to see if there are
important insights
they can take away and add
into their urban planning.
So if we talk about the
integration for a second--
we need to integrate the data
into their current systems.
This is really key because they
don't have a lot of visibility
right now except their road
sensors or traffic cameras.
And due to cost restrictions--
these things are
very expensive-- they tend
to be only on major roads
for cities who can
afford them at all.
So this is a first look at
extending for them, the what's
happening and where--
help me understand
what's going on in my city.
Second, they see this
as a way to communicate
with their citizens.
And they spend a lot
of money and time
trying to gather
this information,
and they need new ways to let
people know what's happening,
what they're doing.
So some examples here are
the parade information
after the New England
Patriots Super Bowl victory.
Due to weather, nobody
knew until the last minute
what time it was going to
be or what the exact route
was going to be.
So they came to us and
made sure that they
were able to communicate
to all of our users
in Boston what the details
were and keep people updated.
Latvia is another good example.
They have very strict
rules on snow tires,
and they will start
fining people the day
after the rules say that
they need to have them on.
So we were able to send a
message to all of our Wazers
to make sure that they were
able to know exactly when they
needed to have these tires put.
Latvia was very
happy about this.
NYPD is another partner.
And recently they
changed the speed limit
across the entire
city and needed a way
to reinforce and let
New Yorkers know.
So they were able to use
Waze for that as well.
This is an example of a
variable message sign.
These things cost a lot
of money, and many of them
are just sitting
there empty and blank
because the data sources
have been too expensive
or it's been too
difficult to integrate.
So we're now
providing these cities
with travel times in real
time, as well as alerts.
For example, snow and ice.
And then thirdly, analysis
has been key for our partners.
Once they have this
much data, they
need to understand
the meaning of it.
And so this is an example from
the Brazilian elections in Rio
last year.
They had two, and the first
is what you're seeing here.
This is Waze reports before
and then during the election.
So you can see that the
number of reports grew by 103%
just in that one day.
What you're seeing on
the right-hand side
is every single
neighborhood in Rio.
The ones in red are an
increase in reports,
and the ones in
blue are a decrease.
So they were able to--
for the second election--
make sure that they
redistributed traffic personnel
in a way that made
sense based on really
what people were
experiencing on the roads.
So this was a very nice example
of making an improvement based
on this analysis.
So on average, Waze
users report an accident
30 seconds after they occur.
This is significantly lower
than what people normally
see from having to call
in or even from sensors.
Even in Sydney where we
don't have a huge user base,
we're contributing an
additional 30% of new incidents
to their traffic
management center.
And 47% are coming
in through Waze
before any other mechanisms.
We also have cities that are
optimizing their traffic camera
placement based on where
accidents are happening
or where congestion is
happening on a changing basis.
So, some other really
interesting ways
that people are looking at
improving their cities based
on data is, Boston Wazers
are reporting an average
of 900 potholes a month.
And they are committed
to fixing them as a city.
So this is good.
You know, it's one
thing to report.
And it's another thing to know
that you're going to report
and something will be fixed.
Washington DC just
outdid Boston with what
they called Potholepalooza.
And so for one week, anyone who
added a pothole through Waze
saw that it was fixed
within 48 hours.
This is great
government response.
We have live snow plow
and garbage truck feeds.
So Rio has even changed their
garbage collection routes
based on this data.
And the Kentucky
DOT is letting users
know when the roads have
been cleared in real time
so they know when they
can get on the road.
LA is also taking it up a
notch in trying to soften
their peak commute times.
And it can be a
difference on a commute
in LA in the morning between
30 minutes in two hours.
So they're trying to
incentivize best times to leave
for work using Waze data.
If you leave 10 minutes
earlier or later
you might save 30
minutes in the long run.
And so we can now
surface this information.
So citizens are reporting,
and cities are listening.
We're playing an active
role in trying to turn data
into better mobility.
And the underlying theme
we've been talking about here
is really that governments
have access to more data
than ever before, citizens are
open to sharing and reporting,
but citizens expect action.
Cities have an obligation
now to respond,
and the most successful
local governments are already
using data to take action
and improve mobility
based on citizen
communication and insights,
literally taking all
this data and using it
as intelligent infrastructure.
So, if you're a developer or
a planner for a city or a DOT,
please join mobility leaders
from around the world
to share best practices
and crowdsourcing,
data analysis, real time
response to citizen needs,
and help spread the word.
Get your cities involved.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]